hello thank you thanks for having me
hey everybody how are you morning real
pleasure
uber and airbnb they're not anomalies
they're the preview everything is going
to be eaten up all human inefficiencies
can be solved and you all know that in
this room thank you guys there's some
guys I don't think Jordans gonna let me
eat this salad ball the two we've got
access to this big wake and we're going
to start our like yard games tournament
well at six we'll go to the stadium
after dinner at the stadium like our
lounge my go to fun fact is I once
judged the Miss America contest I'm
super bitter about this morning and I
really blame myself
the baseline jumper and that was like a
wide open shot my guy was tough
yeah this is tough those crafty his
crafty he tried which is bad I hate guys
that try no effort is such a variable in
games like that hello
in New York we have like seven charter
buses but we really needed five like I
looked at how many empty seats ours I'm
very impressed with you guys this is
exactly the perfect size super efficient
those New York Dolls so fancy
is that a goosebumps hat yes that's
pretty awesome I think that goosebumps
hat is at least 30 bucks on eBay
would you take a hundo yeah she was
right what about 60 Monica 40 how much
money would he take to the good folks at
Gare he wants to know like for real for
real
I'm gonna find him one my guys named
Google it's called who's comes hat
he's trying to drive your present yeah
500 yeah like I will miss Xander's
championship literally game for a Jets
game and it's not even like a debate
which means that I have to be smart
about that cuz that's obviously
emotional and I can fight me in the but
yours down the line so I have to like
really push my kids towards Saturday
activity things yeah I'm by the way I'm
being dead serious about that oh yeah oh
yeah like they really like Misha is
really actually starting to like like
get into it which is really cool and Xan
Sanders Sanders like will do anything
Nisha does like he's like you know he's
he's a four year he's a four year old
girl that's who he is right now like
it's all recital he's just a four year
old girl so the Knicks have a really
cool tradition they play a afternoon
game during Martin Luther King Day like
a even earlier than normal like a 12
noon game so I decided last year that I
was gonna start a tradition and take
Misha and then Xan the kids but Misha
too
that will be our thing like Martin
Luther King Day like I'll stay in the
city we'll go to the garden
what spend the whole day will be like a
nice little tradition so I take her to
the first game I don't know if you guys
saw my snapchat or Instagram I got
season tickets on the floor so we're on
the floor of Madison Square Garden and I
bring me shot it's like a really
emotional moment for me because I
realize this is her first game and my
first game was in the last row the
singular last row of Madison Square
Garden
so it's just kind of like you can start
like really like being like wow we
really made it as a family like and I'm
like Misha like I grab him like do you
know what key you are that you get to
sit right here right on the court and
daddy's first game was all the way up
there and she goes you sat in the
balcony you're so lucky
just classic that's that's I went down
Jesus Christ
buddy mouth is insane is warm
but I figured yeah you know there's
water on there that we should probably
get to yeah you don't need a dressing
right not yeah we're gonna dump dressing
on that
Jesse could be super-strong straps look
at those [ __ ] calves just natural
infrastructure for success
my go-to fun fact is I once judged the
Miss America contest
remember that yeah how quickly did you
get pulled over after you got your
license five days after I got my license
I was driving from the Phillipsburg mall
back home big and I you know I just had
this freedom and I went to go buy
baseball cards Sisley make some money
and I dragged two of my friends cuz it
was fun but my buddy's like holy [ __ ]
I'm so late to get home he's like
freaking out so my [ __ ] so we bribe and
we're like we're in the country like
we're Jesse and I grew up this looks
like [ __ ] in New York City we're in this
back road and there's a car in front of
me that is going for and and the road is
straight the road super straight and I
could see everything and I'm scared to
like go around him because I've been
driving for four minutes right like you
know like I'm still scared I'm still
like totally like you know like the way
Jordan still drives it sounds like and
so I'm like you know I'm super like that
and so I'm like and they're like and the
guys like please and like [ __ ] okay so I
go around it and my third friend who
goes oh [ __ ] that's mr. Wilson mr.
Wilson's my neighbor so now I'm like
[ __ ] mr. Wilson's gonna tell on me so I
like put my foot to the pedal I go fast
and I like roll through this stop sign
at the bottom of the hill and sure
enough a cop stair pulled me over comes
up and he's like not that agitated but
he looks and he sees a bunch of what he
thinks are beers and the mics on my
floor of course this was during my great
drink Stewart's root beer 24/7 365 so so
that get you know we get through that
first angst moment I put the [ __ ] is
that I'm a good steward see you know
he's a go pick it up it was like a hawk
the whole thing so so finally he's a
little bit like he's happy that Stuart's
like I'm winning him over like I'm doing
my thing and all of a sudden this is how
far ahead of that guy went the guy had
passed stops and tells the cop that I'm
crazy reckless [ __ ] past him on the
other side almost hit him cop freaks on
me and drives me home drive
sascha work 24/7 Sasha's not home but my
mom is the best part of this story best
part of story top takes me home wants to
talk to my mother we ring the doorbell
cuz I'm like I don't know Athena right
my sister answers who's three years
hearing me looks and has a huge smile
she was the worst she was literally the
one she's the best but she was a bad guy
she's a bad guy she really is that was
that's how I got pulled over that was my
first experience I really uh I really am
on a mission I really want my life's
legacy to be that I built the biggest
empire in business I'm good I'm very
passionate about it and the cool part
about having that mission is it starts
by me delivering for you guys I'm
interested in people when they're post
vaynermedia I feel like this is a club
would I prefer that you're here forever
yes I would yes I like continuity I'd
like to think that you love it so much I
want to build something long and forever
but if you're not I'm okay with that
so as happy as I am and as happy as
maybe 80% of the people are here there's
nothing wrong with you not being and I
want to have those talks because
ironically 90% of the time it's
literally like a tweak or two and then
you are and you know I've been on this
rampage the last two weeks in New York
and like I would say eleven people have
taken us up on it and their lives are
completely different I would never want
anybody to work so vaynermedia to have
any angst or not happiness under way to
work and that's what I that's what I
feel I do for a living I've never
I don't know it's just insane like a
company that tries so hard to make
people I like against the bottom line
yes so but you know it's chipping that's
what I do I just chip away chip away at
oh that's why I don't overreact or panic
like the truth is a truth yeah like the
truths gonna win yeah like I don't need
to like I don't need to tell people that
I was giving money to yeah don't do that
just not people that are closest to will
know they'll tell something like the
truth the truth finds its way yeah you
know I'm not worried about what people
think about me now I worry about what
people think about me when I'm finished
yeah I mean you know you have like a
stadium full of people first time I've
been to a stadium where a professional
game was going on and I saw none of it
not a play pretty night good day